I was once on top that I fell off how do
I regain my energy levels carom to just
realize you've got no [ __ ] choice
what I don't think people realize is
you've got no choice but to get back on
the game right - like really attack to
take to go like either you dwell on your
misfortunes or you are where you look at
them as you know chips on your shoulders
to make you better like I think
romanticizing around losses is
interesting like it is look like for my
life that just uh it's just uh it's just
a mindset like like you know like I
think the problem is that people get to
a place where they don't want to go
backwards because they get fancy right
they get accustomed to a certain
lifestyle they want certain things and
like for me I love the game so much more
than the riches that come along with it
and so you can get real cozy and
comfortable with nice homes and nice
trips and and dinners but the truth is
like I don't know for me it's like you
know I prefer not to you know go
backwards but if I have to I have to
because I made mistakes and the market
made me pay for it you got to love the
fact that the game is fair and like
that's it and like too many people like
it's unfair it's super [ __ ] fair like
[ __ ] went down and that's it like of
course it's fair like it is what it is I
think everything's fair like your
parents you know died in a car accident
is that the most devastating thing in
the world of course it's just like it's
foundationally devastating the problem
is at that moment in the crisis of your
life you either decide to dwell and use
that as a crutch for the rest of your
life
or you decide that you want to you know
bring value to your parents legacy and
come through for the dreams they had for
you and like that's a mindset that's a
DNA thing that's an environment thing
the thing that I've realized is my mom
and still so much confidence in me my
circumstance of being the oldest you
know born immigrant kid it still did
confidence in me my environment my
natural DNA my mom you know a million
things happened and now all I want to do
is instill confidence in others right
you know I just want to I wanted to
distill confidence in others you know I
just uh oh I thought is muffled
I know can you guys hear me I love hello
hello hello hello so no it's um anyway I
don't know if you can hear me but bottom
line is real simple like I'm trying to
be here everyday for everybody and bring
value to you guys so that you guys can
feed off my energy and optimism and and
and me in some way through my
communication style instilling
confidence in you or giving you courage
feels like an incredible opportunity for
me to get back to the game that's been
so good to me and so I have a level of
gratitude and probably some level of
guilt of how good my DNA is how good my
circumstances I got blessed being an
immigrant and coming from you know not
much and and having so much charisma and
hunger and all that [ __ ] and so anything
I can do through my documenting through
my live streams through my five
Instagram posts a day anything I can do
to you know be a different voice from
the negative voices around you whether
that negative voice is in your head
whether that negative voice is coming
from your parents whether your negative
voices are coming from your co-workers
or friends or you know girlfriends
boyfriends that's it and so like when
anti Sarala says bro chill with the acid
it makes me smile when everybody says
give me the drugs you're giving to
yourself or this guy's on coke or
whatever it is it makes me happy that
can't hear me anyway makes me happy
because when I know that I don't even
put Advil into my system okay when I
know that I've never even tried smoking
when I know that it's super hard to stay
positive and super easy to be cynical
which means I'm trying so hard every
[ __ ] day that it's so much harder to
be optimistic and positive and so you
know it is what it is like at the end of
the day I care so much for you to feed
off of this and on the flip side I don't
give a [ __ ] outside of Liz Novello who's
in this was my sister
like I'll give you everything I got do
you rock and if you don't take it [ __ ]
you right that's just the way it is like
I don't know I don't know what else to
say you know I can only do so much and I
try to give as much as I can and I ask
for nothing I want nothing from you
other than a couple little hearts a
couple little thanks those emails those
comments you guys know my oxygen it's
simple your your your comments your
likes like you know much it means to me
when you guys engage with my social
content when you subscribe when you
leave a comment when you when you just
say thanks when you like a post when you
leave a comment on youtube or retweet a
tweet or you know that's all I ask for
in return just up ahead not an
acknowledgment I appreciate you trying
so hard to give value um you know that's
it that's the trade I'll give you
everything I [ __ ] have every [ __ ]
secret that pops into my dome every
tactic that I've got every connection I
can give you every hello I can give you
any acknowledgment I can give you my
three seconds of tension when we run
into each other at the airport answer
you when I can give you the best content
that I can give you the blueprint that
got me here when I can produce invest in
production of content at scale try to
[ __ ] extract everything that's in my
[ __ ] soul for you for free and just a
little little like you like a little
sherry share a lot of subscribe you
scribe that's all I ask for in return
you can keep your money I'm playing for
your admiration and I want to earn it so
that's my spiel that's me
that's what I'm playing all time [ __ ]
legacy all time the great like I want to
be the great entrepreneur of this
generation
there'll be people will make more money
than me they'll be people that invent
more but nobody's going to give a [ __ ]
about their audience more it's not
possible you can only tie me and
at work you period
you